[Applaudissements]
j'adore alors soleil mais blake est
évidemment aux effets descente est de se
faire plaisir déjà tous les cadeaux qui
vous fait la grave je serai présent j'ai
les coordonnées de encore vous savez
bien ce titre vous aimez bien thierry
moreau plaque m
je sais que beaucoup de gens ont dit
voilà je vous le dis vous n'êtes pas
voilà est jeune et tout à l'heure il
sera sans son épée et vous pourrez faire
ce qu'on me briefer vous allez ur c'est
pas parce que je veux vous voir avant
l'émission qu'est ce que je vous ai dit
soyez gentil avec thierry brault je
serai gens d'ici se dit la vérité
tu peux me tutoyez bien sûr nommé parce
que c'est c'est pour les besoins de la
téloche était quoi alors qu'elle touche
une belle idée de la vérité je vous ai
dit je vous ai dis bien sûr des gens
vrais de vrais madrid vol cartonné
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]